if you couldn't get your hands on an NES  classic and there are a lot of you you  might have a chance at something else  this year I'm Tony and this GameSpot  news update is pretty super the NES  classic has been discontinued but  according to a report from Eurogamer  Nintendo is currently developing an SNES  classic this is allegedly one of the  reasons why the company decided to stop  producing NES classics though we've  heard no official comment on that so the  question is if this is real what Super  Nintendo games do you want to see  personally I'd love Super Mario RPG and  a Link to the Past but go ahead and  leave your game wish list in the  comments below and be sure to subscribe  to keep up with all the Nintendo rumors  and reports  eurogamer's report says the SNES classic  will launch quote in time for Christmas  this year  so we'll see what happens for now you  can get your Nintendo fix with any of  our fantastic zelda breath of the wild  guides  [Music]  [Music]